Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: John Ockey
Volevo fare la cantante, e invece sono qui
a provare a raccontarvi
come ho fatto a diventare una fotografa,
anzi di come è successo.
Credo che tutto sia iniziato
con i miei disturbi alimentari:
io mi sono ammalata
all'età di 14 - 15 anni,
non lo ricordo ancora con precisione
ma ci sono davvero
tanti pezzi di quel periodo
che ricordo ancora
in maniera molto confusa.
Ero un adolescente,
e come ogni adolescente
mi guardavo e non mi piacevo.
Ma non era soltanto
un non piacermi a livello fisico.
Era qualcosa di diverso:
come se, all'improvviso,
io non mi riconoscessi
nell'immagine che vedevo di me.
Credo che l'adolescenza
da un lato sia il momento
in cui iniziamo a vederci
un po' come una prima versione
di essere umano definitivo,
e quello che vedevo non mi corrispondeva.
Credo, però, che proprio
questa non corrispondenza,
questa sorta di scollamento
tra me e l'immagine che vedevo di me
abbia avuto una parte fondamentale
nel farmi poi avvicinare alle arti visive.
La fotografia è arrivata
qualche anno dopo,
sugli scaffali della biblioteca
comunale di Reggio Emilia,
la città in cui sono nata.
E la prima persona
che ho iniziato a fotografare
sono stata io.
E fondamentalmente poi, vi dirò,
insomma, non ho praticamente mai smesso.
Fast forward:
mi iscrivo al DAMS, mi laureo,
frequento una scuola di fotografia,
mi diplomo, non proprio in quest'ordine,
e decido di essere pronta
per provare a fare il mio primo
vero progetto fotografico.
E quindi decido di lavorare
su qualcosa che conoscevo molto bene:
i disturbi alimentari.
Io, da adolescente, volevo dimagrire:
però prendete questo termine "dimagrire"
come una metafora.
In realtà volevo diventare
la persona che sentivo
di dover diventare - e fin qua...
Solo che volevo diventarlo immediatamente:
il tempo che doveva passare
tra quella me così imperfetta,
che ero allora,
e quella me perfetta
che naturalmente sarei stata nel futuro
era un tempo che doveva passare
il più velocemente possibile.
Era un tempo inutile,
un tempo angosciante, un tempo vuoto,
al contrario del tempo della fotografia:
la fotografia per me riempie il tempo.
Quando si ha una macchina
fotografica al collo,
ogni momento è, potenzialmente,
un momento denso di significato,
importante ed irripetibile.
Forte di questo strumento materiale,
la macchina fotografica,
ma anche mentale insomma,
sono partita per Todi.
Era il 2006, residenza Palazzo Francisci,
che è uno dei principali centri in Italia
per la terapia dei disturbi
dell'alimentazione.
E ancora mi ricordo
che viene organizzata
questa riunione plenaria,
con tutti gli operatori,
e le dottoresse, le pazienti.
Mi ricordo queste 20 paia di occhi
che mi guardavano terrorizzati,
perché ero un'estranea,
e per di più un'estranea
con la macchina fotografica.
D'altra parte,
io ero terrorizzata quanto loro.
Infatti, dopo aver parlato,
esserci presentate,
per una settimana - dieci giorni,
non ebbi il coraggio
di fare nemmeno una foto.
In compenso,
passai il tempo con le ragazze,
guardavo la televisione, giocavo a carte,
ho imparato a fare
delle orrende sciarpe a maglia.
Finché un giorno arrivò
questa ragazza, e mi disse:
"Vabbè, ma insomma,
queste foto quando inizi a farle?"
E quindi cominciai questo progetto,
che ha il titolo "The Odd Days",
i giorni dispari,
da un brano di Ludovico Einaudi
che ascoltavo, all'epoca, ossessivamente.
E all'epoca non sapevo
né che questo lavoro
sarebbe durato più di tre anni,
né che la fotografia
sarebbe diventata la mia professione;
e nemmeno che, in sostanza,
questo lavoro sarebbe stato
più di un semplice mestiere,
ma sarebbe stato anche, per me,
una forma di comprensione di me stessa.
Di terapia, a volte lo chiamo.
Non so se anche a voi capita,
ma a me è capitato
che ci siano stati degli incontri
nella mia vita lavorativa
che hanno segnato dei punti
importanti del mio percorso.
Uno di questi incontri
è stato quello con Simona.
Simona l'ho incontrata nel 2008
a Palazzo Francisci,
dov'era stata ricoverata.
Era un'estate torrida,
il centro era pieno, pieno di pazienti.
E Simona, all'inizio,
mi colpì per la sua fisicità.
Era alta, è ancora alta,
molto bella:
questi capelli neri folti,
questi occhi enormi.
E magrissima, magra da morire.
La ricordo,
stava sempre seduta in disparte,
e anche le altre pazienti
era come faticassero ad avvicinarsi a lei.
C'era qualcosa,
in questo alone di estrema sofferenza
che si portava addosso,
che attirava e respingeva
le attenzioni, il parlarle,
allo stesso tempo.
Io stessa ci misi svariati giorni,
prima di decidermi ad avvicinarla
e a chiederle se volesse
farsi fare una fotografia.
E lei mi rispose con quella fermezza,
quella dolcezza che negli anni, poi,
ho imparato a conoscere.
Disse: "Sì, ma non oggi. Domani.
E vorrei che ti immaginassi
qualcosa di bello".
Wow, ok.
Passai il resto della giornata
a cercare di pensare
cosa potessi fare di bello
in quella situazione.
La mattina dopo mi svegliai,
mi fermai da un fioraio
e comprai dei gigli,
perché in una sorta di augurio
mi auguravo che dalle sue braccia,
lunghe e nodose,
a un certo punto potessero
sbocciare dei fiori.
E questo è stato l'inizio di un'amicizia
che a breve sarà
al suo decimo anniversario.
Nel frattempo, non ho smesso
di fotografare me stessa.
Era come se questo guardare fuori da me
mi costringesse violentemente,
in qualche modo,
a guardare di nuovo dentro di me.
Tante cose che credevo di sapere di me
ho dovuto rivederle, e cambiarle,
proprio grazie a questo lavoro.
Dopo questi tre, quattro anni di lavoro
sui disturbi alimentari
sentivo che la spinta
che mi aveva portato
a lavorare su questo tema
andava esaurendosi,
ed entrai in una fase
di tremenda confusione.
Nel frattempo,
la fotografia era diventata
il mio lavoro, la mia professione.
Mi chiesero se volessi andare
nella Striscia di Gaza.
E così, presa dall'entusiasmo
e dalla confusione,
dissi di sì senza pensarci.
E nell'arco, letteralmente,
di pochissimi giorni
mi ritrovai in una zona di guerra.
Ero di nuovo terrorizzata,
non sapevo che cosa aspettarmi,
e forse non ero abbastanza
preparata ad andarci.
Però partivo da un pensiero:
io sono stata la prima donna
della mia famiglia
a non avere vissuto la guerra.
Le mie nonne hanno vissuto
la Prima e la Seconda Guerra Mondiale,
mia madre è nata sul finire
della Seconda Guerra Mondiale,
io ne avevo solo sentito parlare.
Eppure, era un po' come se questa storia
scorresse anche nel DNA
della mia famiglia, e nel mio stesso.
Così decisi di lavorare
non sulla prima linea,
di non documentare la prima linea,
ma di stare a casa con le donne,
e vedere quale normalità,
e se ci fosse, una normalità.
Ma a quale normalità si poteva aspirare
in una situazione di un conflitto
così efferato, e così di lungo termine
com'è il conflitto israeliano-palestinese.
Pensavo: "Se cercavo una familiarità,
se cercavo una corrispondenza
con la mia vita e con la mia esperienza,
avrei potuto trovarla ovunque,
bastava cercarla".
E così, ad esempio, con Obi Wafa.
Wafa aveva perso tutto
durante l'operazione "Piombo Fuso",
operazione militare israeliana del 2009.
Aveva perso la casa,
aveva perso un figlio,
Ibrahim, di nove anni, rimasto ucciso.
E a un anno di distanza,
la prima volta che la incontrai
ancora viveva con gli altri
cinque figli e il marito
in una tenda, nel luogo
in cui era sorta la sua casa.
Wafa pensavo che fosse
una delle donne più distanti da me,
come background culturale,
come scelte di vita, religione.
Parlavamo lingue diverse, figli,
tutto quello che vi potete immaginare.
E invece, con Wafa
io mi trovavo benissimo.
Andai a trovarla molte molte volte,
nel corso di questi anni,
come tornavo a Gaza; l'ammiravo!
Era una persona,
è una persona estremamente forte.
Se c'è una cosa che ho imparato
da questi viaggi, da questo viaggio,
è stato un po' l'abbandonare
una serie di stereotipi
che avevo sugli altri, e anche su di me.
Il più delle volte mi è successo
che dove pensavo di trovare
delle differenze insormontabili,
in realtà io abbia trovato
delle grandi somiglianze.
Fast Forward: 2015.
Stessa cosa in Kenya.
A un certo punto, incontro Natasha.
Natasha è una ragazzina keniota
di 13 anni, all'epoca.
Che cosa potevo mai avere io
in comune con questa ragazzina?
L'ho incontrata in una scuola, a Ilbissil,
a poche ore di macchina da Nairobi,
dove si era rifugiata
dopo essere scappata
dalla mutilazione genitale,
dalla sua famiglia,
che voleva praticarle
la mutilazione genitale
per poi, come spesso accade
in questi paesi, farla sposare,
solitamente ad un uomo
anche molto più vecchio di lei.
Natasha quindi era scappata,
era finita a vivere
per le strade di Nairobi.
E poi era stata presa da una famiglia,
che l'aveva presa a servizio.
Ma in realtà era più una schiava
che una vera e propria
collaboratrice domestica:
veniva maltrattata, molestata ecc.
Fino a che, appunto, non venne salvata
e portata all'interno di questa scuola
che ha una sezione apposta
per le ragazzine che scappano di casa.
E Natasha era molto interessata a me:
aveva imparato un po'
di inglese, per strada,
e quindi aveva deciso
di prendersi il compito
di essere la mia guida
all'interno della scuola.
E mi seguiva dappertutto,
mi mostrava tutto,
e voleva sapere
tutto quello che io facevo,
come essere una fotografa,
come fare a viaggiare e così via.
Quindi, una volta tornata in Italia,
decisi di pagarle la retta scolastica.
Insomma, si può dire
che io mi porti il lavoro a casa.
Ma è una fortuna, è un privilegio enorme.
Quando avevo 18 anni,
volevo fare la cantante,
così mi iscrissi a un corso
con Sainkho Namtchylak,
che è una cantante siberiana,
della Repubblica di Tuva, veramente,
che amo moltissimo.
E al secondo, terzo giorno
di seminario andai da lei e le dissi:
ho la stoffa per diventare una cantante?
Posso farcela?
Io avevo 20 anni.
Lei mi guardò e mi disse qualcosa
che suonava un po' come:
"Ah, voi occidentali.
Sempre a pensare soltanto
al risultato, e mai al percorso".
E ci rimasi malissimo, chiaramente:
infatti ancora oggi
mi ricordo perfettamente
di quella giornata.
Non so se avevo capito esattamente
cosa mi volesse dire,
ma mai me lo sono dimenticato.
Forse, pian piano, ho iniziato a capirlo
proprio grazie al mio lavoro.
Il mio lavoro mi costringe a guardare.
Mi costringe a guardare gli altri,
e mi costringe a guardare me.
Non mi permette di rimanerere,
come vi dicevo,
dentro gli stereotipi che avevo
e che ho, volente o nolente,
sull'altro e su di me.
E forse, tutte queste donne
che ho conosciuto,
Wafa, Natascha, Simona e moltissime altre,
sono dei pezzi di quella me
che da adolescente volevo diventare.
E forse, la storia del mio lavoro
è un piccolissimo pezzo, anche,
della storia della mia lenta,
lentissima guarigione.
Grazie.
(Applausi)